معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد اذا كيف تتفاعل
اسرائيليا قضيه الشكاوى الجنائيه المرفوعه
ضد
هرسك اسرائيل لا تبدي انها قلقه من هذا
الشان والمعلومات التي وصلت الى اسرائيل
تشير الى ان الادعاء العام في سويسرا
استوضح الامر من الخارجيه السويسريه التي
قالت له اولا ان ليس هناك حق لطرف ثالث لا
علاقه له ب ب طرفي القتال او بالقتال
الدائر في ملاحقه اي من المسؤولين فيها
والامر الثاني ان الرئيس الاسرائيلي
هيرتسوغ بحكم منصبه يتمتع بحصانه
دبلوماسيه ومساله ملاحقته
قضائيا بناء على شكاوى سواء بتهم جنائيه
او غيرها غير قائم ويبدو ان هذا طمان
الجانب الاسرائيلي لذلك هم لا يبدون اي
قلق ديوان الرئيس الاسرائيلي يقول بان
هيرتسوغ قد انهى مهمته وانه شارك في مؤتمر
دافوس ومثل موقف اسرائيل هناك بخطاب القاه
لذلك هم غير قلقين حتى الساعه ومساله
التفاعل لا تبدو انها عاليه او انها تثير
القلق او حاله من المبالاه في لدى
الاسرائيليين انفسهم هذا
الموضوع وان كان مزعجا بعض الشيء لهم لكن
يرون بانه من الناحيه القانونيه والسياسيه
والدبلوماسيه فلا خطر على الرئيس هيرتسوغ
من وراء هذه الشكوى بتاتا بعد الرد الذي
وصل للادعاء العام في سويسرا من انه
سويسرا هي طرف ثالث لا علاقه له بهذا
الصراع او القتال الدائر حتى تلاحق احد
طرفيه
بتهمه جنائيه او غيرها كما يشيرون الى ان
الجهه التي قدمت هذه الشكوى لم يكشف
النائب العام او المدعي العام السويسري
عنه يتها وعن اهدافها والموضوع لا يتصدر
لا الاهتمام السياسي ولا الاهتمام
الاعلامي في اسرائيل حتى هذه
الساعه طيب وليد ماذا عن هذا الاتصال الذي
جمع بين بايدن ونتنياهو وكل الحديث عن
موضوع حل الدولتين كيف يتفاعل اسرائيليا
كذلك هذا الموضوع هام للغايه في نظر
الاسرائيل كونه الاتصال الاول بين بايدن
ونتنياهو بعد قط
استمرت من الثال من ديسمبر الماضي اي من
نحو شهر ثانيا يشار الى انه جاء على خلفيه
ثلاثه امور الاولى وهو انه عندما كان وزير
الخارجيه بلينكن في اسرائيل قبل نحو
اسبوعين زيارته عمقت من الخلاف مع رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو تحديدا حول الرؤيه
الاسرائيليه لليوم التالي لانتهاء الحرب
على غزه ومساله ضروره مضاعفه ادخال
المساعدات الانسانيه الى قطاع غزه والعمل
على تقليص العمليات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
اي الدخول بالمرحله الثالثه وتخفيف او
تجنيب المدنيين الفلسطينيين ويلات الحرب
جاء الاتصال الان بين بايدن ونتنياهو على
قضيه حاول الامريكيون ابراز بانها ركزت
بالاساس على ان حل الدولتين ممكن حتى في
ظل قياده نتنياهو الى اسرائيل لكن نتنياهو
كان قد استبق هذه هذا الحديث مع الرئيس
بايدن بمؤتمر صحفي اعلن فيه بانه ما دام
رئيسا للوزراء في اسرائيل فلن تقوم دوله
فلسطينيه وهو في ذلك وان كان يخاطب قاعدته
الانتخابيه اليمينيه العنصريه المتطرفه
الا انه يعود على مواقفه المعهوده ويرى
الاسرائيليون بان هذا الاتصال ربما كسر
الجليد الذي كان يتحكم في العلاقه بين
نتنياهو وبايدن لكنه ايضا يشكل خطوه الى
الامام فلم يختلف كثيرا موقف الامريكي
الداعم لاسرائيل في هذه الحرب وتناول
بالاضافه الى مساله ما تسرب من الولايات
المتحده بخصوص ان حل الدولتين هو الحل
الممكن وان ومحاوله توجيه القياده
الاسرائيليه لقبول في ذلك جاء ايضا ليعكس
الخلافات الدائره داخل دائره صنع القرار
الاسرائيليه بخصوص اليوم التالي للحرب
والحل لان هناك مواقف
يمثلها الوزيران في مجلس الحرب جانس وايزن
كت من معسكر الدوله وكذلك جلنت وقادت
الاجهزه الامنيه والجيش الذين يحاولون
الدفع باتجاه ضروره ان يتم بلوره وا اتخاذ
قرارات ووضع خطه لليوم التالي للحرب وهو
ما يعارضه نتنياهو بشده ويرفضه لانه يدرك
جيدا بان هذا سيدخله في صدام مع حليفيه
المتطرفين
بنفير وسموت ولذلك هو يحاول منذ ثلاثه
اسابيع يتنصل من ادراج هذا الموضوع على
مائده او طاوله البحث في الطاقم الوزاري
الامني السياسي المصغر المعروف بالكابينه
الاتصال الامريكي جاء ايضا ليعزز اتجاه
جانس وايزن كوت وجانت وقاده الاجهزه
الامنيه لكن نتنياهو يبدو على موقفه وهو
يكتفي في هذه المرحله بان الاتصال الهاتفي
وبعد شهر تقريبا من القطيعه بينه وبين
الرئيس بايدن كسرت جليد بينهما وهو ما من
شانه ان يساعد موقفه حتى الذي اعلنه من ان
الحرب ستتواصل حتى تحقق اهدافها حسب
تعبيره اما الامر الثاني الذي كان على
جانب من الاهميه هو يتعلق ايضا بم مساله
الجبهه مع لبنان واتصال الرئيس الامريكي
ونتنياهو كان يبحث في كيفيه ان تبقى هذه
الجبهه الى حد ما هادئه الى حين انتهاء
الوضع على الجبهه الجنوبيه والمقصود بها
جبهه غزه هذه المواضيع التي تدار بين
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل هي في نفس
الوقت تعكس عمق الخلافات الداخليه في
اسرائيل نتنياهو متهم من قبل الاسرائيليين
واعداد متزايده بانه يعمل على دحرجه
المسؤوليه عن الفشل الذريع الامني
والعسكري والسياسي سواء في السابع من
اكتوبر الماضي او في اداره الحرب محاوله
دحرجته على القياده الامنيه والسياسيه
ثانيا هو متهم من قبل ذوي
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في قطاع غزه بانه
لا يضع قضيه اعادتهم على راس الاولويات
وهذا الموضوع كان مركزيا في الح حديث بين
بايدن ونتنياهو حيث يرى بايدن ضروره العمل
بجد و وضع هذا من اجل اعادتهم وذوي
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه الذين
اعتصموا منذ الليله الماضيه امام فيلا
ومسكن نتنياهو في بلده
كيساري على جنوبي حيفا هؤلاء يرون بان
نتنياهو قد اهمل قضيه ابنائهم خدمه
لمصالحه السياسيه الحزبيه الشخصيه وقد وقد
تم الكشف اليوم عن انهم اجروا اتصالات مع
القياده المصريه تحديدا مع جهاز المخابرات
المصريه من اجل العمل على بلوره والدفع
بمقترح بهذا الخصوص ويرون بان مصر
والولايات المتحده وقطر قادره على تقديم
مقترح قد يحرج نتنياهو ويلزمه على القبول
به من اجل اعاده ابنائهم شكرا لك وليد
العمري مدير مكتب الجزيره كنت معنا من رام
الله